I'll tell you one thing
um I never thought an animal could
change my life
it's it's unbelievable
I mean I never in a million years and
then you have a dog and or anything any
kind of animal and you love it so much
unconditionally and they love you
unconditionally to come home and have
that presence to have that just wake up
with kisses to take care of someone to
try and give something a good life they
want nothing from you Michael when was
the last time a dog borrowed 10 bucks
from you when was the last time the dog
bought you a drink when you left called
you an SOB the thing about animals is
they're honest they're honest if they
don't like you you know about it right
away so I I think that's what people
appreciate about listen I gotta be I
don't think I could walk into a house
without an animal I know I couldn't do
it I I they they make you feel so good
they're a real calming effect mellow and
they just make you a better person I
don't want to know people I don't want
to know people that don't have animals I
think animals make you a better person
what does your shirt say uh no this is
the hugs and kisses none of my friends
woke up right
actually they go to the website the
petshow.com you're modeling this shirt
on the website yes okay so to listen to
you you still have radio programs that
are all over the country what is the
show it's called the pet show obviously
we have a local show here in Los Angeles
on krla radio and then we have a
national Canadian show uh which goes all
over the United States Canada we even
heard in Guam uh also called the Petro
Nets on Radio America the best way to
find out or check it out is is go to the
website it's easy enough to remember
thepetshow.com just remember the the
page and by the way if some of the the
listeners have questions there are
literally hundreds of YouTube videos
there and all like why does my dog do
this why does my dog hate my boyfriend
you know I have people call me up I got
a call last week that said to me if my
dog doesn't start liking my boyfriend we
can't get married
I agree with that 100